hey everyone what's going on i just got
out of a screening of a spider-man no
way home and it was awesome this to me
is the best marvel film we have seen
since
avengers end game
it surpassed my expectations
it was
more than i thought it was going to be
i cried i laughed i cheered i was
just awestruck by this film that's my
spoiler-free thoughts of the film but as
i said as you can see in the title of
this there's going to be spoilers in
this review all right i'm warning you
guys right now there's spoilers you
ready
three
two
one
here we go spoilers are coming up now
everything that we thought was going to
be this movie based on the rumors is in
this movie all three spider-man toby
maguire andrew garfield tom holland in
together multiple scenes not just one
scene but in many many scenes all the
villains of course goblin sandman
electro uh lizard
doc ock are there they are integral
parts of this film
charlie cox is matt murdock
he is peter parker's lawyer yes
i'm a huge fan of the netflix series and
it is so great to see him back i cannot
wait to see what they do with him of
course you know because you got to have
spider-man and daredevil team up you
gotta have it i mean just like the
comics it'll be an awesome pairing but
that is the consensus of the spoilers
now let's talk about a little bit about
the storyline what you see in the
trailers is pretty much the first part
of the film peter parker dealing with
the the fallout of people knowing who he
is some people
think he's still a hero some people
think he's a murderer is it you know
very polar opposites going on in the
community and around the world
and so it has affected his friends and
getting into schools and doing things
with her life so that's why he goes to
dr strange to sort of create this spell
to you know help them out as we saw in
the trailer he screws it up by fiddling
with it as doctor strange is creating
this spell and then the multiverse
cracks open so to speak strange is able
to contain some of it so to speak in
this spell that he locks into a box
and that box is precious because if they
open that box that's it everything goes
haywire and you don't know what's gonna
happen
happen
so
that's really sort of the the crux of
the beginning of this film
now along the way of course as we saw in
the trailers doc ock comes into play the
goblin's there and
peter parker
for some reason
this was the one this is one of the more
frustrating things about
his character the way it's portrayed in
the last three films he's he wears these
rose-colored glasses on all the time
even after he went through everything
with avengers infinity war and end game
and
i mean it's kind of a little bit
frustrating i that to me is i i they're
going to move away from this of course
they they are now and you see it
throughout this movie that was the part
of the film that i liked the least
because he just makes some really stupid
decisions where you're like dude like
come on it's not
you're better than this you know more
than this anyway along the way they were
able to capture most of these villains
initially they're in this chamber below
dr strange's home strange wants to send
them back to their world and they all
find out that they actually each of them
die in their own respective universes
which tom holland's peter parker is like
i don't want that to happen strange is
like it has to happen this is their
destiny you cannot screw with the
multiverse this way you cannot screw
these timelines this way anyway
peter parker
he wants to help them
so him and strange get into a little bit
of a battle they go into the mirror
dimension yada yada yada then they end
up uh peter parker ends up besting
doctor strange taking his magic ring and
his magic box he gives it to ned he
gives it to mj says keep this safe uh if
anything happens to me then you open
this box or whatever the case may be to
sort of
i don't know because the box was sort of
confusing it's like does it open up the
multiverse if you open the box or does
it get rid of it it's
this part of the film was a little bit
confusing to me i need to watch it again
to sort of uh
understand it but
something bad's gonna happen tom
hollands peter parker wants to
rehabilitate these villains he brings
them back to happy's apartment who has
this star tech inside of it basically
it's like a
compact lab that opens up it's got ai
and robots and all this stuff that you
can create you know various different
you know chemicals machines i mean
whatever you can you create everything
right
so
he ends up helping doc ock by
reprogramming that chip so it's in the
back of his neck so he controls the arms
off the arms control him hence makes doc
a good guy
uh then he's working on serum for the
goblin of course this device to take out
the electricity out of electro and also
a sort of
another concoction it you know turn
lizard back into a human [ __ ] hits the
fan when the good william defoe by the
way because he is the goblin and he's in
this movie a lot he's actually one of
the main villains by the way um
the bad side of his character
kind of uh pulls a fast one on peter
parker goes and pretty much creates
havoc and
yeah the villains go crazy they get out
of it peter parker uh peter parker
spider-man and the goblin really have a
big big battle and at the end of it
ant-may
dies
that's right marissa tomei passes away
um this is the moment of the film that
it really changes tom holland's peter
parker uh tremendously it's this is
where it gets really dark and very very
serious before it was a little bit
comical a little bit cheesy at certain
points you're like
i don't know what this movie's going
and this is where it really changes
at this point
he doesn't know how to handle it he runs
away
and uh then you see ned and mj trying to
find peter but they don't know where
he's at he's not answering his phone
they can't get a hold of him so mj mj's
like i'm going to press this button to
release this put this spell out of the
box like you know
peter told her to do
dad's like no don't they were talking
all this and he's got that ring on his
head he's like waving his hand just
talking all of a sudden you see sparks
and then
it's kind of like that the beginning of
the portal opening right so he does it
again he's like oh they see sparks more
and then does it again then a portal
opens up and they're like peter because
they see a spider-man there
this is what's really cool and you see
spider-man turn around look at them
and they're like peter
we've been looking for you come in here
you see the spider-man like huh what and
he walks in
and it's andrew garfield's
peter parker spider-man in the outfit
right and the audience just erupts right
and and it's really cool because they
try to they're all like stunned like
you're peter parker and he's like
yeah and then
you know i mean obviously they don't
understand this whole multiverse concept
but the funny thing is actually andrew
garfield's character sort of got it
right away um he's a bit of a nerd in
that regard so once they started trying
to explain what's going on he pretty
much was on board which i'm glad they
did this because you don't want
everybody to be like huh what's going on
what's going on you've got to have some
characters that sort of get this
multiverse gist or get this idea better
than others so looking for peter again
they open up another portal and then
toby mcguire's spiderman comes out but
he's dressed in just normal clothing and
i mean the crowd erupts again and then
you see these two spiderman talking to
each other like you're peter your peter
it's great it's funny the chemistry
between
toby andrew and of course tom is
awesome
this
makes the film
it really does everybody else takes a
back seat to these three guys they it
was just so cool to see anyway
so they still can't find their peter
parker then
i think there's andrew garfield said hey
is there a place that he likes to go
when he you know you know things are
tough or what he needs to think and then
mj's like yes i know a place it's the
rooftop they always go to
they end up meeting him and of course
you know tom hollands peter parker's
full of ven revenge and hatred and anger
and he wants to kill the goblin
and he's you know and those the other
two partners peter parkers are like look
we know what you're going through he's
like you don't know you don't get it and
then they really have this it's a
beautiful scene it's uh it's just it
really touches your heart because
andrew garfield is so good he is so good
at peter parker he's so good at the
emotions and
what he went through is like
honestly in a lot of ways he stole
the show when it came to all three of
the peter parkers and spiderman there he
kind of stole it in my personal opinion
he was just awesome anyway so they all
kind of share their stories their grief
that they went through and their
journeys of spiderman a little bit
and uh
okay we're able to sort of find that
common ground so they want to
rehabilitate the villains and the way
they do this of course is through serums
and you know devices to sort of uh you
know take
those powers away from them to make them
normal again make them human again
so they all work together in the lab
doing this and it's awesome and this is
where the chemistry comes into play with
all three
there's a lot of funny moments in it
this part these things i'm not gonna
spoil for you you have to watch this and
enjoy it but it's just
brilliant writing and brilliant acting
so then of course they decide they're
gonna do this thing they're gonna go to
the scaffolding they're gonna as you saw
in the trailer they're gonna accept all
three spider-man in there they're gonna
lure all the bad guys there and then try
to you know
uh give them their respective devices
and serums to cure them
anyway
[ __ ] hits the fan doesn't go as you
think it's going to go the goblin is a
menace he's out he's out for blood
uh you know and they can't seem to grab
they can't seem to work together because
they've never worked together before tom
hollands peter parker course has worked
on a team so he sort of like guides them
like okay we're going to do this we're
going to do that then they start working
together and it's awesome to see all
through spiderman swinging around and
doing their thing and you know and
everybody's wise cracking do and talking
[ __ ] and it's fun it is just awesome
then of course we get to that pivotal
moment in the trailer right you know
where mj falls off
and she's falling
and then you see tom holland's peter
parker diving after her it's of course
spider-man diving after her you see the
hands almost there and then the goblins
take some off away and she's still
falling
andrew garfield's if he sees this he
just
dives off the edge of it goes down he
catches her
right in the nick of time the crowd goes
they just burst out cheers in the
audience
and then as he's holding her he's like
are you okay
and then you could see that he had tears
on his eyes because it reminded him of
gwen stacy but he was able to save this
woman and then she looked at him and she
was like are you okay like because he's
quite emotional it's quite it's quite
cute he's like yeah i am it's nice to
see that that they really really tapped
in a lot of the interesting arcs and the
character development these k that these
actors had through their own journey
spider-man they all brought it into this
i mean they even have funny moments when
you even talk about toby maguire's like
how he can shoot webs out of his arm
like it's built inside of him and they
have to use contraptions on their on
their suit so
it's it's there's a lot of fun moments
anyway
um doctor strange is able to get back
into the mix because ned opens up
portals change comes back
he's able to sort of uh repair a lot of
this stuff
and but the one thing he has to do to
repair it
and is to make sure that nobody
remembers you know tom holland's peter
parker
and uh you know tom holland says yes i
want to do that
and that's pretty much
how no way home ends in a sense that you
can't that nobody remembers him mj
doesn't remember him ned doesn't
remember him nobody does
and there's some really beautiful scenes
at the end of the film where he sees mj
again and it's it's really touching and
the chemistry between zendaya and tom
holland is just awesome
um there is a pivotal moment uh a fight
between the goblin and tom holland's
spider-man towards the end of the film
that is uh really really visceral
but
he learned something along the way in
that fight and it's um
the way they did it is awesome because
you think it's gonna go one way and it
goes somewhere different but yet didn't
quite go there i don't want to give too
much i don't give that portion of the
movie away this movie's got so much
heart so much humor it was great to see
all three of those spider-men uh there
and you know
i feel bad for andrew garfield and toby
maguire and people trying to ask these
actors over and over again are you in
spider-man leave the poor actors alone
let it be a surprise to the audience i
mean as a reporter they should be
smarter than that they should really
should but you know everybody wants that
that five minutes of fame as a reporter
to you know
spoil something when you just let them
let us as the audience enjoy the film
as i'm telling you a spoiler-filled
review anyway that's because i'm warning
you in advance uh anyway those are my
thoughts on spider-man i loved it i
absolutely loved it there are some
things i haven't told you in this some
really touchy moments some great moments
but i am
i'm just [ __ ] amazing and by the way
there's two post-credit scenes
one of them
is to do with venom
the other one has nothing to do with
spider-man
it is sort of a trailer
to the doctor strange
movie the multi multitude of madness or
and the other
is about doctor strange too that's all
i'm gonna say anyway
that's it
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below if you watch this
video if you want to ask me questions
i'll answer them for you thank you so
much
watch this movie it's awesome and
i can't wait to see it again anyway take
care stay safe i'll chat to you soon bye
you